so with one out here's story
and that is a line shot to center field
spun the cap of garrett richards and
here's charlie
this ball high in the air deep right
field speaking of home runs how about
that start chuck nasty make it two
nothing colorado welcome home boys
first home run of the season for chuck
nasty great way to open up this
season
tommy pham leads it off against john
gray
and this is going to be a tough play for
nolan bare hand to fur
out at first base
the magic of nolan arenado on a field he
knows so well off the bat even with
nolan i thought this probably going to
be an infield hit because fam runs well
he does but nolan comes in and gets a
nice hop though that was the thing that
helped him it wasn't a case where he
really had to go down too far to get it
one down for the padres here's machado
bloop towards right center field moving
over his doll he slides and dives and
makes the catch in the alley
what a play by david dahl taking at
least a base hit maybe two bases away
from manny machado david got a very good
jump on that ball
and there's a situation where
a right-handed throwing outfielder in
center field can make that play because
he doesn't have to backhand it he could
just reach with his left hand
02 onto t swung on and missed and that
is
the second strike out of the ball game
for john well worth that second base
grisham at first one out padres trying
to make some noise here
2-2 pitch
and his flare to right field that ball
is going to get in for a base hit around
from second base comes cronenworth the
throw will go to second base and the
padres are on the board they cut the
rockies lead in half it's 2-1 manny
machado drives in a padres run
here's profar
check swing got behind tony walters all
the way to the wall they cover the plate
they make a throw he scores and the
padres have taken the lead for the first
time today it is 3-2 in a three-run
sixth inning it was tough to see what
was going on there so a really good read
by machado but great help offered by
profar who immediately waved him home
brian mcmahon coming up
there's a broken bat blind drive into
right field for a base hit
murphy is headed to third and the throw
goes there the tag will be in time
nicely done machado slaps it on murphy
and he is out thrown out at third base
for out number two a lot of first third
action here in colorado as soon as will
got that ball even though it's the third
base side manny machado gets stretched
out very athletic play he's got to go
from one side all the way to the other
murphy has a dirt sandwich and manny
makes a spectacular play well this is
why they went out and got kemp inch hit
d-h
and camp drives it to left it's got a
hook on it matt kemp comes through
mcmahon scores to tie it green light for
hilliard he's coming home throw to the
plate not gonna get him
just like old times and the rockies lead
it four to three
you know max gonna score but i just we
talk about it all the time the
aggressiveness of stu cole
sam hilliard is running hard i mean gets
those long legs and that long stride
going
and then not even close
at the plate he ends up in scoring
position representing the tying run at
second base two outs here in the seventh
and tatis
and this one is lying to right field
that's going to get in for a base head
mejia being waved around blackman's
throat coming in it is cut off and the
padres have tied it up fernando tatis
junior drives in the tying run
it'll bring up trevor
in the air deep midfield way back and
god
story has struck again
why not it's the home opener that's his
sixth home run in his career in the home
opener and the rockies go in front again
five to four
fernando tatis jr
and tati sends it to left field hillyard
going back at the wall it is gone a home
run to tie the score for fernando tatis
junior with two outs in the nine tatis
takes it out of the yard and cores and
the padres have tied it up
fastball
middle in and he knew he got it queen
otto fernando and the intentional walk
served up to machado puts runners in
first and second they'll take their
chances with tommy pham
sam hits it in the air to left field
hillyard going back at the oh it's gone
tommy fam with a three-run home run puts
the padres on top eight to five
tommy fam has come up big for the padres
in the night
they're loaded up for mcmahon here we go
three and two
ball four and now the rockies within a
run
pomerantz comes into the game trying to
get the final out of this one 2-2 again
in the air to center field grisham going
back he's got a beat on it he will make
the catch of the padres hold on to win